[Music]
so uh a man
has a very interesting method for
dealing with his landlord who's a real
pain in the a is it gonna escalate very
quickly
uh well
he had um a disagreement with his
landlord
um about the way that you know he was
able to live on his property i see and
the landlord was maybe giving him a
couple of rules that he didn't really
agree with it's like you can't cook meth
in this apartment yeah i don't
they didn't say exactly what
but he was like okay
he's like i'm gonna try
um killing him and eating his heart yeah
i figured this is gonna escalate in
about that that
degree that's a really good solution i
think it's interesting yeah i mean
it's probably one of the most sensible
things i've ever heard it's not bad
right because
you just think we all we've all had
landlords a little pain in the [ __ ]
egg yeah i [ __ ] hate landlords
my landlord's
yeah i've only had some nightmare to
deal with i've had a nightmare lord you
never wanted to eat your landlord no no
never wanted to eat his heart
no very very nice people
very cooperative so so this man um
he he was suffering delusions and he he
believed that he was
god oh he was god or that the landlord
was god he believes that he's god
and god gets hungry and god needs heart
i'm starting to believe this whole issue
has nothing to do with the landlord at
all i don't think that's true but we'll
find out i think the landlord's the same
problem let's not jump to conclusions
guys remember the landlord's being
problematic right i don't think so dude
okay i don't think so at all so he
thinks he was god and he was on a
special mission against the forces of
evil in the world as you do as god
i mean too fast righteous missioning
yeah dude
like if you really believe that in your
head i'm gonna [ __ ] kill my landlord
why does the craziest [ __ ] always have
to involve christianity like come on man
why god and all that just think of
something else because he doesn't
technically have to be christian does
that mean all homeless people are
christian
pretty christian because they're [ __ ]
crazy i bet there's a good percentage
they're hella christian bro yeah i was
at the uh they all hate abortion dude i
was driving
i was driving over here
a [ __ ] ambulance from behind me
there's a [ __ ] homeless guy on a bike
one like this the ambulance goes
he drives by him and then the homeless
guy flips him off like this
i'm like what the [ __ ] and the whole
time after he's gone ready he's still
cussing at him as if like he had the
right away yeah justified if you're on a
bike you're supposed to be pulling to
the right
that's true i'm like i don't know he's
[ __ ] cyclists don't like to follow
road rules
protect cyclists guys all cyclists all
cyclists don't get it so this man um has
a has a condition
they believe called schizophrenia no
really
the japanese guy's over there
other identity what
yeah i'm a schizo my other identity is
god so apparently he's been receiving
treatment for schizophrenia since 2011
but he's off his meds but he was off his
meds for 18 months
that's a long time and those
premonitions stew up there for 18 months
so then um god built this [ __ ] world
in seven days
so then
then he kills his landlord
and he boils his heart
on a stove damn he actually boiled it
yeah
wow that's gonna be much more uh tough
then no oh no it's probably easier to
eat like chewy because
like you gotta like pull that i think
you put it in a traeger you know yeah
yeah slow cookbook
triggered he said boiled it right you do
santa murphy i would do it differently
oh yeah yeah for sure what kind of
seasoning yeah what would you put on a
heart first of all i would put i would
do the wood chips yup in the traeger
so it's like smoky i like that yeah i
think a smoky heart actually is kind of
tight i like it grilled because i like
the grill marks on the meat you know
let's don't get a girl mark on it grill
much but it's still gotta be kind of
smoky i feel like it's gonna have a
barbecue to it it's like heart you know
brian introduced me to chicken heart
syrup pretty [ __ ] good chicken looks
pretty good chicken hearts are good
they're not that bad yeah i like them
japanese style yeah that's right yeah
yakitori yeah
we just yakitori like human hearts
should be like kind of the same but it
would just be this big right grill
anything well do you think if you like
slicing a couple pieces and it grows so
you get more cookage and more flavoring
you know it probably cooks more evenly i
feel like a heart's really thick like
you're putting it all the way through
yeah the grits is hard it's like three
times too small you know well landlord's
heart would be smaller though because
yeah they're they're
because they're greedy i think the
closest thing i've had
was beef heart and it's nothing like
chicken heart because it's nothing like
human heart what does it taste like i
never had beet heart before it's a
little bit more livery and it's big as
[ __ ] so it's a lot of iron flavor so it
feels like gamey it's like kind of yeah
it's much more gamier
but you know how like everyone's doing
this whole like liver king like phrase
where everyone's eating organs yeah
what's with that they're like
carnivorous and [ __ ] where they just eat
raw [ __ ] meat and they put in like
ziploc bags while they're pregnant they
start eating [ __ ] [ __ ] everyone used
to go that's so nasty but now everyone's
like there's so many vitamins and great
things inside it so we should [ __ ]
eat it we should eat it raw yeah but
also cook it though no no no if you're
liver king you just eat it raw yeah that
jacked guy right he's a lubricant that
guy that's definitely not on [ __ ]
royal wolverine or some [ __ ] no no he
just delivered him has nothing to do
with hugh jackman he makes wolverine no
no there's another guy named i think the
wolverine or some [ __ ] that does the
same thing we did article here about it
[ __ ] i wasn't here for that yeah
jesus
um solo article
so this guy this guy um was found not
guilty by cleveland saying what i
believe insanity what just because he's
cuckoo yeah cause he's cause he's cuckoo
[ __ ] coco puffs for sure i wonder how
he did it like how he got his landlord
in how he killed him he was he was
probably
just probably like hey you're [ __ ] my
place up like you need to get out of
here blap it would have been sick if you
did one of those days
i like that i like it
oh so crazy no honestly this
another weird part of the story is the
when he killed him they were believed to
be having an argument over a game of
chess
that's what it is
that's how it starts imagine sitting
through a whole game of chess and then
killing the guy at the end of it and he
[ __ ] got killed
if he hit him with a [ __ ] frying pan
on his head he knocked out he [ __ ]
cut his heart open he took it out and
then he [ __ ] had to clean it up and
then put it inside the boil oh my god
that's so nasty it almost sounds like an
unbelievable story like you know if you
like where uh someone's like i could
tell your fortune you're eating out of
norms or something and you know
sometimes those crazy ladies just come
up to you do you want to know how you're
going to die you know like fine tell me
you're going to have a tenant that's
going to eat your heart no yeah whatever
after a game of chess yeah i became a
chess that's [ __ ] crazy that is
something a crazy lady tells you about a
waffle house yeah yeah that's true and
then it's [ __ ] cool and you hear
stories like this and my man maybe they
know something they do but how come
they're always poor if they know the
future how come they can't even [ __ ]
go out and come you can't make the right
decision maybe it's only like eighty
percent maybe like that lady was like
checkers and that's wrong oh [ __ ]
chinese checkers maybe maybe they're
really honorable oh and they don't use
it i don't want to use this for personal
there's rules this is just like a genie
you can't wish for certain things
unfortunately you can't do that there's
no number yeah but jeans are sneaky
though jeans are gonna [ __ ] you over
they'll take last minute and [ __ ] yeah
they'll twist it it's like oh yeah i
want to have sex with like the hottest
woman on the planet and then they make
you [ __ ] someone who's on fire yeah
that's where i was going i can't believe
this [ __ ] i hate it when they do that
have you guys um seen those movies like
where they're like [ __ ] hunting and
[ __ ] like like i don't know like [ __ ]
gone with the win or some [ __ ] or like
dances with wolves or some [ __ ] right
they [ __ ] kill a buffalo and they cut
the [ __ ] heart out and they're like
[ __ ] eating that [ __ ] raw do you guys
think you could do that well that was in
the uh uh redead uh
revenant revenant right there retention
right he definitely crawled inside that
the horse or something like that i know
the
moose or something like that yeah for
warmth yeah he did the old he'd do the
old han solo
the old tantan yeah
i would do that would you be able to do
it what's the benefit of eating it's a
ritual oh really you're absorbing their
life force makes your penis bigger like
thank you
it was just beating and [ __ ] so it's
like it's primal yeah yeah so before all
the parasites and bacteria was like yeah
and when you like cook stuff like
moisture nutrients and stuff actually
goes away from the cooking so
technically if you can eat something
like mad raw that's like the most
nutritious version yeah because i heard
that like when wills [ __ ] hunt and
[ __ ] like they go straight for the
organs yeah like they want that they
don't want the [ __ ] meat they want
the nutrients and the fat not
necessarily the the meat muscle we we
eat so much like okay meat you know what
i mean i actually want to try it i would
try it i don't know if that's my go-to
because i still might want to cook some
of the ribeye parts but what if it's
super delicious after you take a bite
you're like and you can't go back you go
oh then i'll probably stick with we'll
just go to chinese hot pot today [ __ ]
eat all the weird [ __ ]
sorry about living we'll get accidents
in the back they probably could have the
guy with live moose in the back oh maybe
that's true you never know so in in the
tradition of just kidding news um i i
would like to
end this video with a classic question
what shirt was he wearing
that's really good but not close
hawaiian shirt probably so if you guys
were diagnosed with schizophrenia and
you had a landlord what would you do
[ __ ] tickle his balls what
you